alyssa's backstage and kevin is behind
these walls ready to re-pop the question
in the most romantic way um and alyssa
has no idea so um
should we bring this out
okay
alyssa come on out
how are you how are you oh i'm so good
so nice to meet you thank you for having
us thank you so much for showing up
absolutely happy valentine's day happy
valentine's day i love valentine's day
me too
well you've been married now for three
years yep almost there will be three in
august three in august
um and um will you tell us about your
husband kevin yeah so um
he's
really funny that's i think that's kind
of what attracted me to him
like originally um he's hardworking
he's a great
dad to our kids speaking of kids um your
husband um
his proposal
uh actually involved one of your
children yes can you please tell me
about that so um
he was down on one knee and his daughter
kaylee was filming and
we were focused in on the moment and
then
we kind of looked at each other because
she started laughing and we didn't know
why she was laughing until
he got up and then we saw my son owen
who was at the time three and he was
peeing behind kevin and we had no idea
so isn't that just so life yes like it's
so perfect also you guys said you love
to laugh and humor is everything yep but
why do you think you're here today
uh to talk about being newlyweds oh okay
well actually we have a little surprise
for you um
kevin uh actually wanted to uh do a
little something
about that engagement situation so he
actually asked us to get involved i hope
you don't mind kevin are you there
oh my god
[Music]
am i getting up yeah
right there oh okay haley from our
initial introduction
i knew you could be the one
from our first date to the ferris wheel
[Music]
but no tickets necessary while i was
part of our journey
kaylee owen olivia and i appreciate you
more than anything in this world
we may not show it all the time but we
do
[Music]
i love you
ellie
oh
oh okay can you marry me
again
yes
[Applause]
[Music]
come on up here for a second
we just wanted to
provide you a nice
beautiful uh safe space
filled with flowers and good energy and
cool neon lights and an extraordinary
artist and music
and uh also simon g jewelry that is a
very beautiful ring um so
that was sparkling like nobody's
business did you guys see that i was
like is this thing glowing
it's so amazing uh they gave you this
handcrafted beautiful diamond 18 carat
white gold ring and it really is
stunning um i did think it was lit from
within um so um
i also heard um that kevin had to work
through the entire honeymoon too is that
is that correct that's true
honeymoon well
that's not fair
we'd like to do something about that too
um we're gonna send you on a luxurious
seven night eight day stay and fijian
style bungalows at yasawa island resort
resort in fiji
i've never been to beijing that sounds
so amazing and it includes meals and
activities and you're also getting round
trip airfare provided by fiji airways so
now you can have a real honeymoon
every amenity thank you
thank you so much
[Music]